Hey, this is funny that we have a voicemail
number.
That number is two one nine two David P, there's
a caller who's been calling in off and on
for years.
I know him as the Kansas troll and this is
a guy who once called Sam Cedar to argue about
Sam Cedar, fellow progressive hosts to argue
with Sam about the bell curve.
And uh, you can see this viral clip on Sam's
channel.
It's called something like stupid young man
or racist young man calls in to argue about
race or something like that.
It's the Kansas troll.
This is the same guy.
And he's gotten through to me live before
he talked to me something about Alex Jones,
his supplements or something like that.
He called in and he had a critique to me about
how the show is doing.
Take a listen to this.
Hey, Pac-Man.
I mean, Hey members, membership sales man.
How's it going buddy?
Uh, I see that, uh, now after your advertisers
have, uh, fallen down a bit, uh, you're selling
a lot of memberships.
I mean, most of these internets goes, they're
asking for 10.
If you ask for seven, then you went down to
five and now you're, you're offering $2 a
month for members that, I mean, gosh, bagman
just offer it for free.
That's what it's worth at this point.
C'mon.
You're not going to get more members.
Your show's going to fail.
It's going to collapse soon.
You've been doing this for over 10 years.
It's not going anywhere.
Just give it up.
Dave.
You know, when I hear that, I would love to
see what this guy's been up to over the last
10 years.
And what's, what's amazing about this is that
first of all, membership prices have been
unchanged for something like eight years.
And a lot of shows raise membership rates.
We've kept the same rates, six a month, 60
a year for a very, very long time.
And of course we offer discounts to people
who can't afford to pay the full rate.
Um, what's funny about this is that we are
regularly contacted by other shows, independent
shows and media outlets.
The rap interviewed me last week specifically
about how we've built this membership program
because it's so successful.
That's what's incredible.
And in 2019 alone, so we run the membership
programs since 2010 we doubled, nearly doubled
our members in 2019 so from 2010 to 2018 we
grew membership in 2019 alone, we have nearly
doubled membership since 2018.
It's incredible actually how it's doing.
And you know, this is a guy who's been calling
in for a very long time saying, we're just
circling the drain.
The show is ass so close to going off the
air and you know, someday that may happen.
No, nothing lasts forever.
Uh, but not today and certainly not tomorrow,
my friends.
So when I hear stuff like that, that actually
is what gets me fired up to say we want to
have the best 2020 ever thanks to everyone
who's already supported us this year.
Let's try to double membership again in 2020
and those are the types of folks where I,
I used to be really bothered by stuff like
that.
And then I imagine, how has this person's
a business doubled in size over the last a
couple of years?
Has that happened?
Uh, my guess is probably not.
So keep them coming.
It's just fuel for the fire and the fire is
growing.
My friends, we've got a great bonus show coming
up for you today.
Producer Pat wants to weigh in on a number
of different things, including Donald Trump's
latest claims about where he may or may not
debate.
Join both of us on the bonus show today.
Join pacman.com patrion.com/david the David
Pakman show@davidpakman.com [inaudible].